-You were just in Pittsburgh
for Steel City Con.
How does it feel --
Much has been written
about the fact that, you know,
Star Trek was not
anywhere near as popular
when it was airing as it is now.
Is it still surreal to you
that fans are so deeply
connected to that show?
-It's 53 years old.
We went on the air in 1966,
canceled in 1969,
exactly 50 years ago,
and here we are, 53 years later,
with another new Star Trek
spin-off with Patrick Stewart
and another movie being talked
about by -- with Tarentino.
I mean,
it's an amazing phenomenon.
-And people must still be
so happy to see you
when they go to something
like Steel City Con?
-I greet my fans like this.
[ Laughter ]
-You know how to please them.
So...
-We have lived much longer
than we expected
and prospered
in so many wondrous ways,
like all these fans.
-That's fantastic.
This show, "Terror: Infamy" --
this is much more serious
subject matter, and, uh,
it's based on the internment
of Japanese-Americans.
Uh, there's a supernatural
element to it,
but this is a very real
issue for you --
not just being
a Japanese-American,
but you were interned as a child
from the ages five to eight.
Is that right?
-I'd just turned five years old.
A few weeks after that,
my parents got me up
very early one morning,
dressed us hurriedly up --
my brother a year younger
and my baby sister
still a baby, an infant --
and, uh, my father
said to my brother and me,
"Wait here in the living room
while we do some
last-minute packing."
So the two of us were
just looking out the --
gazing out the front window,
and suddenly we saw two soldiers
marching up our driveway
carrying rifles
with shiny bayonets on them.
They stomped up the porch
and, with their fists,
began pounding on the door.
I -- the way I remember it,
the whole house
seemed to tremble.
And my father came out
and answered the door,
and, literally at gunpoint,
we were ordered
out of our house.
And so my father gave my brother
and me little packages to carry.
He hefted two heavy suitcases,
and we followed him
out onto the driveway
and waited for our mother
to come out.
When she came out, she had
our baby sister in one arm
a heavy duffel bag in the other,
and tears were streaming
down her cheeks.
It is a picture
that's burnt into my memory.
-What did you think
was happening
when being that young
in a situation like that?
What were your memories
at the time of what this was
and why it was happening?
-That morning
was a terrifying morning,
but then we were taken --
you know, the camps
were just being built,
so they took us
to Santa Anita Race Track,
a nearby race track.
We were herded over with other
Japanese-American families
to the stable area
and assigned a horse stall
for us to sleep in.
From a two-bedroom home,
front yard, backyard,
on Garnet Street in LA,
to a horse stall.
For my parents,
it was a degrading, humiliating,
painful experience
to take their three children
into that smelly horse stall,
still pungent with the --
and I still remember that smell,
but, for me,
I thought it was fun to sleep
where the horsies sleep.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-You know, horsies slept here.
-Sure.
-I can smell them.
-Now, how surreal was it
for you to return to a set
that was built
to evoke this time
and having such specific
memories of it?
I mean, obviously,
you're coming back
in a much better
perspective on it,
having the control
of telling this story,
but was it hard for you
to walk onto a set
and see those camps again?
-Remember,
I was a five-year-old kid,
and they built
on a 6.5-acre plot of land
an exact replica
of the internment camps.
The barracks were exactly
the way I remembered it.
There was a little crawlspace
down below,
and I recognized that
because we adopted a black dog,
cute little dog.
We named him Blackie.
And whenever something
scared him --
you know, when gunfire
was going off --
he got scared, and he would
crawl under the crawlspace,
and we crawled in after him,
so, you know,
I remembered the details.
The -- The set designers
did tremendous research.
The strips of wood
that held the tar paper on
were exactly
the same dimensions,
so it was, to me,
a kind of a nostalgic return
because of my childhood
experience, but, as a teenager,
I learned a lot more
about the reality --
the harrowing experience that it
was for my parents, and so, uh,
with both the adult knowledge
and the memory of a child,
it was eerie,
kind of, the feeling.